earlier today Senator Lindsey Graham is
should a statement read quote after
today's hearing and for the good of the
country I hope this is the end of the
Muller report now we it's time to find
out how this debacle started and went so
far
senator Graham joins us now your
question I always go back to you asked
Ernie general Barr you confident Muller
had everything he needed to get the job
done at a time
no president never invoked executive
privilege once well I don't want and a
half million documents everybody was
accessible my question is does Hillary
get away with a fixed investigation when
she committed crimes to the people
involved in lying to a FISA Court
consciously do they get away with it
that people that tried to influence a
presidential election get away with it
and people that tried to undo that
election get away with it senator or
you've got to make sure that doesn't
happen I'm more determined today after
this hearing to get to the bottom of it
the question did Hillary get let off
because the people investigating her
wanted her to win and Trump to lose was
the reason that she wasn't prosecuted
it's because of a political decision
political motivations all the things are
very important the one thing I can tell
you after a day the Muller report is in
name only and the idea that you say it's
a good report we'll see but it clearly
wasn't the molar report it's just a name
I had more to do with the Muller report
than probably he did and you know what
bothers me a lot people around Bob
Muller knew he was in a weakened state
this guy served in Vietnam got wounded
done a lot of great things for the
country he should not have been called
senator let me let me agree with you
you know when the Attorney General
agreed to the joint statement Attorney
General I said at the time he did the
favor to bob Muller the Attorney General
was warning this is going to be a
spectacle seems like the only person
that understood and tried to prevent it
was the one that was being accused of
trying to rig it was the Attorney
General knew that this would be a
disaster for Muller and you're right his
background is one of a hero they the
people that allowed this that use
Tim the politicians on that committee
and the people on that yeah on that
group that hired and did all this and he
knew nothing and ran the show without
him they're the ones that did this to
his reputation
the Bentley the hatred for Trump knows
no boundaries they used this this man
and one of the reasons I told people
early on I was not going to call
Muller's because the report speaks for
itself but I was told by people close to
Bob Miller that he really shouldn't have
to go through this they knew he wasn't
capable of this I am a stupid talk-show
host I was told repeatedly he's not up
to the task well here's the point I've
been asked for three months why don't
you want to call Muller I bet you nobody
will ask me that tomorrow I was a letter
was sent to me by every Democrat on the
Judiciary Committee in the Senate why
don't you call Muller nobody's going to
ask me that tomorrow here's where n say
Donald Trump is stronger tonight than
any time in his presidency that need to
find out what happened is greater today
than it was before it's clear that Bob
Muller was not in charges investigation
and like every American who cares about
the rule of law we need to find out how
this started senator been on so long we
need the Senator Graham that changed the
course of the Cavanaugh hearing to take
control of this your country needs you
this is important this Republic came
dangerously close to allowing lies and
conspiracy theories few powerful people
unseat a duly elected president we need
your country did you that's just the
fact well they're there time is coming
the president's gone through he'll for
two and a half years and nobody else
could have taken it but him I know every
day I don't see they're trying to ruin
his family's life and he's tough as
nails but those who who engaged in the
FISA Court abuse and I think fraud it's
their time and the only way you'll ever
stop this in the future is to make
people you're committee is going to be a
crucial senator we we do I know you will
I believe you thank you for you two
going to do to get to the truth